there's a story right now happening
right now within the NFL that also I
think is going to be worth talking about
potentially on the after show since
there's been a lot of coincidences that
have been happening you see this story I
guess it just just happened I'm reading
the chat room and people in the chat
room are talking yeah Demar Hamlin
collapsed on the field in a game uh the
game was suspended so first the dude was
tackled
he doesn't hit his head or anything he
gets tackled and takes the fall to his
left shoulder stands up slowly starts he
walks around for a few seconds then just
Falls right back they started doing CPR
and giving him oxygen and I guess
they're suspending the game
I don't know what happened
um you loaded into an ambulance people
were crying and they're suspending the
game
yo I there I've seen injuries in
football games before I've not heard of
maybe I'm not a big football guy of
people crying
and then the game being suspended did
the dude die
from being tackled like that that's what
some people are saying in the in the
chat room let me let me just let me just
show you the video it's not perfect
people in the chat room are saying that
he did pass away here take a look at
this video does this just happen yeah
this just happened so so all right I'm
slow down all right
this guy right here yeah this guy right
here this is DeMar so there here you go
he gets tackled
he's right here let me play it for you
boom goes down onto his left shoulder
stands right up yeah
didn't hit his head or nothing and then
gone
he hit his head going down he's wearing
a helmet look at that
yeah it doesn't look bad it did not look
bad at all I've I've fallen so much
worse skating I was told by a doctor
recently that if you are to get a
coveted vaccine or a booster that you
should take like six weeks off well he
told me that I or so he was telling
someone I think I was watching a show to
take six weeks what does that have to do
with a football game to take six weeks
off of strenuous labor I don't know if
he has been vaccinated or yeah it could
be totally irrelevant I don't know but
for someone if they're not getting that
instruction and they're getting like
medical procedures or injections or
things like that and then they're just
going full hard moving I mean that can
be a toll on your cardio well Dr Peter
McCullough has uh and um another doctor
have different explanations to it and
and scientific understanding of it
that's being questioned right now uh
Twitter is finally allowing us to have a
platform or a lot of this science is
actually being debated in an honest and
open real way as we recently found out
through through the Twitter files that
of course the White House was
manipulating scientific data scientists
and the actual information because it
was inconvenience convenient for them
and their larger political agenda these
are the factory files that are supposed
to be coming out no no these are the
Twitter files that were released and now
the faucy files are going to right I'm
saying the next step of this we we are
we already know from Twitter files that
got released that because of covet
specifically the government was
intervening getting people to spend like
Alex Berenson was a very big story but
the fauci files are going to
supposedly directly implicate fauci
himself
no
no way no even when we control the house
yeah of course are you kidding oh man
sorry like Kevin McCarthy he's making
all these promises Marjorie Taylor
Green's backing him they they probably
cut some kind of deal so she'd get back
on committees if she supported them
there are people who are saying when it
comes to Kevin McCarthy as Speaker take
what you can get my response is
nope I'm not doing it I don't care I
don't like Republicans I don't like the
Republican party I never did Donald
Trump was something different I didn't
even like Trump in 2016. but then I saw
what he was doing I liked at least what
we got out of polling troops out of the
Middle East getting our getting our
troops out of Syria all that nonsense no
war in Ukraine for instance the economy
was doing pretty well and I was like
I'll take it like there's a Libertarian
element that was able to piggyback
Freedom caucus people people like
DeSantis off of what Trump was doing I
like that I'll take it but now I don't
know what Trump's doing but I'm not I'm
not interested I mean it's it's really
stupid
the things he's put up on Truth social
and stuff whatever I still think he's
way better than anyone in the Republican
state Republican establishment but the
idea that I like someone who never liked
the Republican party is gonna in any way
get behind someone like Kevin McCarthy
is never gonna happen like do the dude
could be sitting here right in front of
me I'm gonna be like I don't care like
yeah
McCarthy called for Trump to be
impeached to be kicked out of office
Michael let me see yeah keep keep
talking but we have this for Michael
malice on January 3rd 2019 Democrats
officially retook the house and elected
Nancy Pelosi a speaker the Republicans
nominated Kevin McCarthy as their
candidate the person who gave the
nominating speech was Liz Cheney yeah
I'm not interested in any of that so
guys if you're a republican Marjorie
Taylor green you're cheering for
McCarthy hey man do your thing Democrats
cheer for Nancy Pelosi they do their
thing fine whatever I don't care
libertarian all the way I'm not I'm not
gonna get behind Kevin McCarthy you guys
down with the mises caucus I like those
guys yeah I like them a lot from uh from
one to a hundred and a hundred is Ron
Paul and one is Liz Cheney where do you
say see yourself on that political
Spectrum
I mean I'll just say that give me a
number give me a number okay
um
a hundred total freedom uh Ron Paul
one just change one one Liz Cheney I'm
explaining it no Freedom total status
neocon neocon is no one 100 is Ron Paul
where are you on that Spectrum I'll say
like
75. okay what do you look interesting
he's 100 I'm 100. he's Ron Paul I'm so
glad you're here I'm 80. come on I was
even critical like Ron Paul when Ron
Paul was running so I'm critical of
everybody Ron total freedom Paul
yeah like I don't want to I don't want
to say 100 because it's too absolute but
I don't want to be even one degree
closer to Liz Cheney yeah I mean well
that's technically where you are so let
me know in the comments section where do
you stand in the comment section 100 to
2-1 let me know your number um I love
the chat room you guys are awesome and
it's great being a part of these
conversations 99.5
a lot of sixty a lot of 69s like uh are
you sorry no you said you said you uh
that Trump would be you know Trump is
the best one so are you Trump or
DeSantis well I don't know if Trump is
the best one I mean if you're from the
Republican party uh he's better than the
establishment Republicans DeSantis is I
think at this point I don't even know
what Trump's doing I'd say DeSantis over
Trump yeah in in like February and April
I was saying I don't know DeSantis is
he's got the tact he's younger but uh I
don't know if he has the aggression
you know Trump look at the way he's
taking on all of the wokeness in Florida
I know I mean I'm not Advocate I'm not
what about you Trump or December I'm not
answering that oh come on here's the
thing is that and did an interview the
other day and they tried they tried
getting me to give an answer and I don't
owe allegiance to any political a tiny
politician they work for us a watch
DeSantis campaign I'll watch Trump
campaign and then I'll make a decision
yeah true though you think you'll yeah
Republican for sure do you just kind of
go with whoever no Republican all the
way for sure have you always been a
republican yeah so what do you think
about McCarthy as a speaker
uh
not fun
I mean
I wish there were other options
um I don't think he'd be my first choice
but I think that just the fact that we
have that it will be a republican
speaker is always is going to be good
regardless
um but no he would not be my first
choice what do you think he wouldn't be
my eighth Choice he wouldn't be my it
would be my 100 this is what we have so
we have to work with it I think I yeah I
get that but I don't have to work with
it no we you know you don't but my my
view is
look I didn't vote for Trump against
Hillary despite knowing that Hillary
Clinton is evil and Trump was just crazy
like I don't mean crazy like insane I
mean he was like yes
more chaotic is probably the way I would
describe it he was more chaotic he was
more arrogant and these things I didn't
think he had the decorum and that's just
me I understand people thought his
attitude is exactly what the White House
needed then I saw what he was doing and
I was like okay yeah this this deserves
a second term like this is good stuff
it's not it's not perfect or anything so
I don't I don't like the lesser of two
evils vote when it came to Biden versus
Trump I was like Trump did things I
really liked he's had timetables for
getting out of the Middle East he got us
out of Syria he did those things there's
a lot of complicated stuff there but the
North Korea peace deals Abraham Accords
all these things I thought were very
good and then I look at Joe Biden and
I'm like he's crooked as they come this
is a no-brainer you know he also can't
get a sentence out I mean he's not
dementia so but now looking at what the
Republican establishment has always had
to offer there's a reason why I've never
voted for them until now because they're
a garbage party and like the funny thing
is when you look at the polling
Democrats mostly like Democrats Democrat
voters mostly like Democrat politicians
Republican voters don't even like
Republican politicians I think
Republicans tend to be people who know
politics but are begrudgingly voting for
the best thing they can get and I'm kind
of like well you know do your thing like
you know I like Marjory Taylor green a
lot and she's supporting Kevin McCarthy
and I'm like oh you know you know go for
it you know by all means like that
that's your thing I'm not a part of the
Republican party I don't like Mitch
McConnell Lindsey Graham or Kevin
McCarthy see I'm not going to support
that if they win or if McCarthy wins I
don't I I see very little difference
between him and Nancy Pelosi I I get it
Pelosi is very very bad but on my
establishment establishment
establishment like I don't know like
when Donald Trump gets elected in 2016
from 2017 until 2019 the established
Republicans worked against him
establishment Republicans were the ones
who helped change the voting rules to
make sure he lost there's no way I'm
getting behind someone like Kevin
McCarthy it's just not gonna happen and
then Matt Gates I think is saying Jim
Jordan and I'm like I didn't care about
that like Matt Gates maybe Donald Trump
for speakers sure I don't even know who
I would support but it's not going to be
any of these guys not like it matters
I'm not in Congress I'm not gonna be
voting anyway so if Kevin look I get it
if Kevin McCarthy wins it's better than
Nancy Pelosi but part of me really wants
to see him lose because it would be the
funniest thing ever after this
apocalyptic performance in the midterms
relative to what people wanted to be
Rana McDaniel still getting support
after all these failures I think they
need to lose I think Republicans need to
lose the speakership when they have the
majority just because of how how
functional they are well look
there's a coalition of of moderate
individuals who are voting Republican
right now because of the stuff you know
for instance you you highlight
but I'm not going to get behind Kevin
McCarthy because the creepos are doing
weird children sex shows or anything
like that like you you are not getting
me to vote Republican because of the
culture War if you if I'm concerned
about these issues I like DeSantis the
Santos is actually effective so someone
like him as Speaker I'm like I like it
he is surrounding himself with
establishment people though so we'll see
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time